not having any free will do you even  care determinism yeah you're free in  some regards and determined in others  the farther out you look in the future  the more your behavior  is free will like and the closer it is  to the present the more your behavior is  determined so if i move my hand rapidly  from here to here  and stop it i dis-inhibit that movement  it's ballistic  i have no free will once i've initiated  the movement i can't react fast enough  to stop my hand i have to pre-plan that  using unconscious mechanisms beforehand  and then allow the program to run  as you move towards action you become  increasingly determined